attends on revient
à 10 km de la frontière russe ces
électriciens s'activent pour réparer un
poste de transformation touché par un
bombardement
vous voyez ce cratère c'est le résultat
d'un tir d'artillerie l'équipement du
poste a été endommagé et à cause de ça
plusieurs villages de cet agglomération
sont sans électricité
la reconquête par l'armée ukrainienne
début septembre les villages ont subi 5
à 7 mois d'intenses combat d'artillerie
ces hommes travaillent avec le risque en
permanence le prédécesseur de Alexandre
est mort en sautant sur une mine et la
météo nette pas
dans les conditions actuelles là où nous
le pouvons nous ne rétablirons la
distribution d'électricité que vers
l'été plusieurs de nos infrastructures
se trouvent à la frontière avec la
Russie et on ne peut même pas y accéder
les militaires ne nous laisse pas passer
dans ce village presque chaque maison a
souffert des bombardements malgré cela
certains habitants ne sont jamais partis
et ils s'apprêtent à passer l'hiver
dans cette cave de 3 mètres sur 3 Victor
et son épouse ont connu l'enfer
je dormais ici avec mon chien et ma
femme dormait là
après dis-moi sans au courant que ni
lumière et une blessure par éclat d'obus
nous dit Victor on s'habitue à tout
mais l'absence de bois de chauffage pour
le poil c'est quand même difficile
par les éclats d'obus je suis rentré et
mes mains étaient gelées car tout est
mouillé
mais sa plus grande peur c'est que les
bombardements reprennent
pourvu qu'il ne recommence pas à
bombarder
sur quelques 2000 habitants que comptait
le village avant la guerre 25 survivent
aujourd'hui grâce à une aide humanitaire
venue de l'étranger